everybody send me these send me these
conspiracy things about agenda 401 or at
the Bill Gates thing and what it's like
guys if they did it if they release the
virus then it's like if they're willing
to do that what I mean woody or do you
even want to know at that point just buy
some heroin and get ready to meet what's
on the other end of this I mean guys at
a certain point well what is uncovering
the truth even [ __ ] do for you I
don't personally believe they did this
cuz I think they want to they would
rather us making money at our [ __ ] jobs
and sitting in the house while the world
economy collapses but if they did and
this is some way to wipe the slate clean
and they're willing to do this well then
what the fine mean god at a certain
point you got a [ __ ] rollover I guess
I don't know I mean I don't know what to
tell ya if Bill Gates release this virus
I mean what are you gonna do you know we
gonna do tweet about it I mean what you
know at that point what you do you have
a militia you ready to go well you got a
few guns in the back you shoot at you
tree in Georgia I don't know if these
people really did that then I tend to
believe that was probably some accident
it's probably a Chinese bioweapon it
probably leaked out of that lab and Wu
Han I don't know how it did maybe they
still were selling bats maybe they're
selling animals that they experimented
on that seems the most probable thing is
it weird that it happened during the
Hong Kong protest yes
but I also think that you know
potentially you know China didn't have
any problem shooting tear gas at those
protesters Charlie didn't have any issue
doing that so I mean is it is it
impossible to say that they released it
to get rid of that no but I don't know
that they did you know it could have
happened you know and again to trying to
release this to just say [ __ ] it let's
see what happens who knows I don't know
I don't know you don't know but what so
as Raycom said I was talking to today
it's like so what's the plan go to the
beach like what
we are supposed to do in fact everybody
that we know is that the move even if we
know it's a bio weapon is to move to
just go out and all get sick and then a
lot of people die that doesn't seem
logical well it's the bio weapon from
China so what you still have to protect
yourself your family to a degree you
have to be ethical you know I have a
friend who's gonna fly to New York to
visit his girlfriend I'm like are you
out of your [ __ ] mind dude what are
you doing this is the stand the Stephen
King miniseries on TV did my father
allowed me to watch because he allowed
me to watch most things in the 90s that
was his style of parenting he said if
you want to watch it you can watch it
the movie se7en sure not a problem
whatever you want to watch you want to
watch dead man walking you want to see a
Sean Penn get lethal injection what are
you seven you'll enjoy this come on it's
playing up the block I don't want to pay
for a babysitter I want to go watch
casino you ever seen someone get buried
alive you're about to handle it handle
it like a man that's a great thing about
boomers who had all had one kid the only
kid houses we would go out with our
parents to dinner with their friends you
know and their friends would talk about
things that were inappropriate for us to
hear but it is what it is if you have
two kids with three kids you get a
babysitter or maybe the older kid will
watch the younger kids in my house it
was like that my sons coming don't
censor yourself my sons coming talk
freely about wanting to kill your wife
talk freely about it my son's there he's
nine he'll think it's hilarious and I
did talk freely about it get hammered in
front of him talk about talk about the
drugs you do he won't mind he'll be
doing him soon he'll be doing him within
two or three years get him ready let him
know let him know you were coked out of
your mind the other night you thought
about pushing your wife out of the attic
window that some of the guy really said
I was sitting there as like 11:00 he
goes you know I look at my wife
sometimes I
want to just push her out of the attic
window because who would know the whole
table of guys just red wine laughing
it's great we're great memories aye aye
aye aye
I appreciate the way I grew up that was
a great style of parenting it's getting
real now on Long Island for even for
people that didn't really grasp because
in the beginning the outlook on this on
Long Island was we you shut the [ __ ] up
that's how it was handled shut up people
have to sit down with the parents ago
you can't golf
you can't go golfing you can't go you
can't have you know you can't go to
Maria's baby shower you can't and you
did have to explain it and there you go
so what nobody's sick you know and now
it's those see those those statuses
they're getting there get those people
are going quiet now they go cuz some of
them are dead but they're going to
getting a little quiet like the it's
just a flu status so that's what I never
make these stupid predict like I never
go out there and I don't take these hard
stances you know when I don't know
something because I've learned that you
could you only have to walk it back so
if I'd come out was like you took the
flu it's all faked of [ __ ] duh I mean we
drove by cedars-sinai one night there
weren't a lot of people there it would
have been easy for me to come on and be
like John or we [ __ ] drove by Cedars
there was no one there they stings fake
umm and then now I would have to be
looking at numbers and you know gotta
walk it back so you know people are
gonna get real quiet you know they're
getting a little quiet because in the
beginning it was this was you remember
that this was a liberal this was liberal
hysteria to to wreck the economy so
Trump would would get voted out of
office this was the this is what I heard
from my people on Long Island and this
was hysteria somebody I knew wrote their
closing the country down because if
sniffles and Long Island loves World War
two memes I'll be like just the greatest
generation and then and then they'll
show like somebody blowing your nose
this generation closed the country down
for sniffles and the funny thing about
that is the people that share those
memes were never in the military they
never served in the military came and
they loved World War two although they
probably did nothing for their
grandparents that served in World War
two other than robbed them the only
thing they did for the greatest
generation was take money off their
mantle okay so but they loved those
World War two memes that are like this
Joe we're [ __ ] now goddamn [ __ ]
this flu sniffles there's still a net
now there's still people doing that by
the way there's still people that are
going you know there's still people with
it the mortality rate and the death toll
and that's all gonna stop it's common
and most people there will be some
people that don't care there will be
people on ventilators right before they
go out you know you know before they're
in a coma there'll be people going so
what this is not I mean it's just trump
2020 will be the last thing certain
people say on long island
Trog that'll be it because you cuz
they'd rather just you know drowned in
their own lungs then unravel their
worldview you know